well let's turn back to cop down shall
we and the UN global climate change
conference is starting today as the UK's
presidency comes to an end and Egypt
takes over Rishi sunak will now fly to
shamal Sheikh as will Boris Johnson to
what's been called the African cop now
this time last year we spoke to the
climate Envoy of the Marshall Islands
it's a country that's already been
severely affected by uh climate change
and today we are talking to Tennessee
again thank you so much for being with
us
today now the climate emergency is very
serious for you the Marshall Islands
could disappear in 50 years can you just
explain to us what the situation is
yes
um
you know sea levels are rising it's it's
already happening uh we've been impacted
by this crisis and we are already seeing
um
islets that have disappeared
uh we're having to think about where and
when people may need to move
to other Islands to Higher Ground which
by the way we don't have
so it's very much front and center for
us and it's an existential it's an
existential issue we don't accept a
future in which we have no future
um and it's for that reason that you
know we're here at cop
um making the case and fighting for
our future
now smaller countries like yourselves
are reliant really on larger wealthier
countries uh stamping up what's known as
adaptation funding to you know protect
you from climate change like the
flooding that we saw in some of those
images that were just on the screen and
you know last year you know cop in
Glasgow promised to double adaptation
funding but of course historically the
money has fallen well short of what's
been promised have you got any faith
that things might be different this year
thank you we need this process to
deliver
the Marshall Islands obviously
needs it to deliver us immediately
we really have no time to lose in terms
of getting started on the adaptation
planning that we're already engaged in
you know we're already having to look at
very difficult decisions on
where people might have to go and what
the future looks like so we're already
doing the work
we chair the high ambition Coalition on
a very big part of that decision at
Glasgow last year that came from
developed countries in terms of telling
our story and having people understand
the gravity of the issue and we're so
happy when we developed countries came
forward with that commitment on doubling
of adaptation Finance but what we need
now is delivery we need to see that when
promises are made and pledges are made
those promises are kept and those
pledges are delivered on and that is
what builds uh trust in this process
that is what leads to success and every
cop
needs to be a success
um for for the entire world
that's the key point isn't it you know
in some ways the commitment to the easy
bit it's the delivery that is difficult
do you sometimes think that these
Summits are a bit like a PR exercise I
guess for some world leaders you know
they construct the stage they can talk
the talk on climate change but then
actually it ends with promises that are
broken
it can't be a PR exercise I wouldn't be
here if I thought that that's all this
that all that's all this was
you know
um the cops have produced some real and
significant progress uh the commitment
to 1.5
um is there because we've engaged in
this process the recognition that
adaptation needs are significant and
need more financing that happened
because we engage in this process
um the signal to the world that in fact
uh Renewables are the basis for a secure
and safe future for all of us that
happens because of this process the
process
is what we have and it could be a lot
better I'm not trying to say that it is
you know
what we need in fact we need much more
action that is accelerated and we're in
an incremental process but it is a
process that gives countries like mine
that are small and that are on the front
of the front lines of voice
and let's face it if um there wasn't a
cop I wouldn't be sitting here right now
talking to you and explaining how
important
um this is and how important it is that
the the world as a as a whole respond to
what is a global crisis in a global
manner
um and so you know
we show up we show up every year it is
not a PR exercise for us and it
shouldn't be a PR exercise for anyone
else
I'm interested to know what it's like at
negotiating the final deals and in
places like Corp you know we just we're
looking at pictures there with John
Kerry you know surrounded by delegates
right at the 11th Hour hashing out last
minute trade-offs
um what is it like in the negotiating
room the smaller countries like yours
have a voice
um it's intense uh
um and it's it's exhausting there isn't
a lot of sleep in this process
uh this is my first week
um we're going to be here for another
two weeks uh you know ask me what it's
like at the very end
um you really do put all of your energy
um your heart
um everything that you believe in into
it and
uh it's extremely intense but as I said
before we're fully committed to finding
Solutions through this process and we're
continuing we'll we'll continue to show
up
okay thank you so much for being on the
program today very busy uh week ahead
for you thank you